-It´s so good to see you,
my friend.
-It´s great to see you, Seth.
I feel like it´s been a while.
-It has been a while.
I feel like we see each other
sort of intermittently
over the last few years.
But we met a decade ago now...
-Yes.
-...on the set of the film
"Hot Rod," the Andy Samberg...
-Wonderful film in Vancouver.
-In Vancouver.
We spent a summer together
in Vancouver.
[ Audience cheers ]
-Yes, yes.
You were up there trying
to save the film -- right? --
trying to put more jokes
into it.
-I was doing -- I was trying
to put more jokes into it.
And I got like two jokes in
over the course of a summer.
-I knew --
I knew which jokes were yours.
-Thank you very much.
-They were the good ones, yeah.
-Oh, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
It was a great summer.
I really enjoyed it.
And you had been --
I remember the guys --
The Lonely Island guys
had found you
from this fantastic independent
film, "Foot Fist Way."
-Yeah, yep.
-But this was your first studio
film, your first big film.
-Yeah, this was the first film
I had ever participated in
where I wasn´t paid in a case
of beer and a quarter of weed.
-Yeah.
-It was the -- It was the --
It was the first real paycheck.
It was incredible, yeah.
-And did you prefer that
to the beer and the weed?
-You know, it goes
back and forth, you know?
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah.
-There´s more stakes on it, you
know, when you get a paycheck.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
You were not at the premiere
of "Hot Rod," though.
I remember us going,
and you and Bill Hader
could not make it to that.
-Yeah, we were riding high off
of the success of "Hot Rod,"
and we were -- Bill and I were
both in "Tropic Thunder."
-A fantastic film, as well.
-Yeah. That was fun.
We were -- And we were in Kauai,
and we -- we were gonna miss
the premiere of "Hot Rod,"
and we were really bummed
because we --
you know, that film
was so special for all us.
We really did love
working on that film.
And Bill and I were like,
"Why don´t we just
crack some beers and, you know,
read some reviews
on opening night
and just see what people think
about this film?"
And we got through
about four or five of them,
and we were like,
"You know what?
This is the worst idea.
We should never --
We should never have read
any of these."
-I will say --
the world came around.
"Hot Rod" was ahead of its time.
-It was ahead.
-Because I will say, it´s a lot
better received 10 years now.
I would say a lot of people
consider it a classic.
-It´s -- That movie is --
I really do think is brilliant.
I don´t use that word often...
-Yeah.
-...because I don´t really know
how to spell it.
[ Laughter ]
But it -- it is awesome.
Those guys did an incredible job
with that.
And I do love the idea that
like, you know,
sometimes, a movie comes out,
and the critics don´t give it
its day in court.
But that is the movie
that everyone
will come up to me about.
You know, they love that film.
-And it´s --
I think that those guys hit
this really
interesting cross-section of,
it´s a really smart,
very well-considered comedy,
and there´s a bunch of jokes
about wangs.
[ Light laughter ]
-Tons of wang jokes.
-And it turns out that, like,
people like that more in 2017
than they did in 2007.
[ Laughter ]
-They were ahead of their time.
-Yeah.
-And then you did a fantastic
show, "Eastbound & Down,"
that was produced by...
Yeah, give it up
for "Eastbound & Down."
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Will Ferrell --
comedy legends
Will Ferrell and Adam McKay.
Was that intimidating to start
working with guys like that?
-It was.
Those guys -- you know,
they picked up our film,
"The Foot Fist Way."
And so we were -- we became
friends with those guys.
And they were like
sort of our mentors
as we made "Eastbound & Down."
And, you know,
those guys were heroes of mine.
And so,
when we made "Eastbound & Down,"
after we finished
the first season,
Will and Adam were like,
"Hey, you know,
you´ve done a great job on this.
We want to, like, take you out.
We want to -- We want to
have some fun with you.
Let´s have
a gentlemen´s weekend."
I was like, "All right.
What´s a gentlemen´s weekend?"
They´re like,
"Why don´t we go to Vegas?
There´s a boxing -- You know,
there´s a boxing fight --
There´s a fight this weekend,
and let´s go see that.
We´ll eat steaks.
We´ll drink wine.
We´ll get massages.
We´ll have
a gentlemen´s weekend."
I was like, "That sounds like
a pretty good idea."
-Yes, it seems like
a very high level of gentlemen.
-Yeah. This is what --
This is what guys do
in Hollywood, I guess.
-Yeah.
-And so, we went to Vegas.
And I had never had
a massage before.
It was just something that I had
never thought about getting.
And these guys were all
very well-adapted to it.
They knew all about massages.
So, we go to this thing.
I don´t really know what to do
at the -- at the, you know,
at the massage parlor.
I´m not really sure
what the protocol is
or what´s supposed to happen.
And we´re all sent
into our different rooms.
I´m like, "What do we do?"
And they´re like,
"Oh, we´ll meet up.
There´s, like,
this giant hot tub
that we can all just, like,
meet up at afterwards."
I´m like, "Okay, well, sure."
Walking around.
Everyone´s naked.
Everyone´s nude walking around
this massage parlor.
And -- And so I´m like,
"All right.
Well, I guess this is
just what we do," you know?
I come in there, and I
kind of strip down, as well.
Like, I get the massage.
It´s like,
"Oh, this is pretty cool.
This is
a nice gentlemen´s weekend."
And...
[ Light laughter ]
...the massage is over with,
and I´m just like
not really sure what to do.
I´m like, "Oh, thanks.
That was awesome."
And I´m like, "Is now
when I go to the hot tub,
where all my friends
are gonna be?"
And she´s like, "Yeah,
I think there´s a lot of people
out there.
You can just go out."
And I´m looking, and there´s --
you know, people are
all walking around naked.
I´m like, "Well, I guess
this is just what you do.
I guess you´re just --
we´re gonna go out there naked."
And so I just was like,
"You know, to be a part
of this experience,
let´s live it up."
[ Laughter ]
So I made the choice like,
"Yeah, you know what?
I´m not gonna go change.
Just go out
to the hot tub naked."
Like, this is a big deal.
And so I walk down the hall
and get to where this beautiful,
gigantic hot tub is,
completely nude.
And then there´s Will and Adam
in their bathing suits.
I´m like, "Oh, nope,
nobody´s naked -- just me."
[ Laughter ]
That was the wrong --
the wrong call.
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
-That´s like...
you -- you broke the first rule
of gentlemen´s weekend.
-Yeah, and then I just,
like, scurried
and dipped into the --
into the hot tub.
[ Laughter ]